Speaker 1: Little good news, though. Let's finish
with this wrong claim. The outgoing chief of
staff of the White House gave a speech and made
this the it's a video of him giving the list of
accomplishments of this White House, of this
administration. And it is when you hear it all
at one time, it really does bring into focus all
of the things that have gotten done, even with a
Joe Manchin and a Kyrsten Sinema standing in the
way of some of the real big progress things we
could have gotten done. Watch. Run, Ron, claim.
Speaker 4: You've heard me say this before,
but I never tire of saying it together.
We passed the largest economic plan,
the most significant one since FDR, while managing
the largest land war in Europe since Truman.
We passed the biggest infrastructure bill
since Ike passed more judges than any first
year president, than JFK and the second largest
health care bill since LBJ. The most significant
gun control bill since Bill Clinton was president
and the largest climate bill passed by any country
at any time, anywhere on planet Earth. All while
managing the worst public health crisis any
president has faced since Woodrow Wilson, with
the narrowest majority in Congress of any new
Democratic president in 100 years.
Speaker 1: It's pretty it's
impressive. It is impressive. But these
things did get done despite the efforts
of Republicans, despite the efforts of the
Independent. Now Kyrsten Sinema and Democrat
from West Virginia, Joe Manchin does. He's a
little out of breath. There are so many things
to mention in so little time. He seemed out
of breath. It reminds me reminds me of that
scene from Liar, Liar, when Jim Carrey, his
character, gets pulled over by the cop. And
then the cop just asked, you know, how fast you
were going or do you know why I pulled you over?
You know I pulled you over. Depends on how long
you were following me. Hey, why don't we just
take it from the top? Here goes. I said I follow
too closely. I ran a stop sign. I almost had a
Chevy. I spent some more. I failed to yield at a
crosswalk. I changed lanes, the intersection. I
changed lanes without signaling while running
a red light and speeding. Is that all? No.
I have unpaid parking tickets. Yes.
Am I right or am I right? Ron Clark. You know
he's leaving the White House because if they
make a liar, liar to. He can. He could play a role
where he says a bunch of words real quickly and
out of breath. Anyway, that
is it for me. Thank you guys,
for tuning in. I'd love to have you connect
with me on social media and here on YouTube,
out there on the social media landscape, I
am at Dallimore, just about everywhere and
right here on YouTube. Just search by stupid name.
Jesse Dallimore or Dallimore Dale. Thanks a lot.